ever since Demon Slayer season 2  finished airing in February of 2022  we've all been wondering when season 3  would be released we had to wait a long  time but in December of 2022 we finally  got the answer now there was some  confusion about the season 3 release  date so I'm gonna clear it up for you  right now some people thought season 3  was getting delayed because they were  making another movie like they did with  the Mugen train Arc that's because they  are releasing the last two episodes of  season two and the first hour-long  episode of season 3 as a special  theatrical release in February and March  but the actual Demon Slayer season 3  will Air in April of 2023 season 3 will  cover the swordsmith village Arc and if  you want to stay up to date on all the  Demon Slayer season 3 news and content  subscribe to anime uproar right now